Jennifer Garner hit the red carpet  Wednesday night for the LA premiere of  her new film miracles from heaven nearly  two weeks after the actress broke her  silence on her split from husband Ben  Affleck in Vanity Fair magazine your  vanity fair article was so open and  honest and rare i think in hollywood and  just wondering what kind of feedback  you've been getting on that article from  people very loving thank you and the  love doesn't end there when it comes to  Garner's new faith-based movie she hopes  everyone who sees it feels inspired  including her young daughters violet and  seraphina I look forward to my girl  seeing it for anyone i hope that they  just take a message of hope and  encouragement and kind of that you can  march through hard things one foot in  front of the other one step at a time  miracles from heaven is in theaters  March 16